YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
15 DAYS FROM ELECTION DAY.
JOINING US NOW AUTHOR OF A NEW
BOOK.
TRUMP THE BLUE COLLAR PRESIDENT.
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI.
I LOOK THE PARTY OF NO
CONSTITUTION ORDER IN THE
KAVANAUGH HEARINGS.
NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
SANCTUARY CITY AND ELIMINATING
ICE.
A PARTY THAT WON'T CONDEMN THE
MOB THAT SAYS THE LEADERS SAYING
CONFRONT THEM.
WHY DO THEY EVEN HAVE A SHOT IN
15 DAYS IS THE REAL QUESTION?
>> IT'S BECAUSE OF THE MEDIA
PROBABLY.
THAT COULD BE ONE.
MANY REASONS.
THE PRESIDENT ON A NIGHT LIKE
TONIGHT.
A RESOUNDING RALLY.
EVERY NIGHT WHEN THE PRESIDENT
IS OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN, HE IS
PUTTING THEM DEEP IN THEIR OWN
ZONE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BACKED UP TO
THEIR GOAL LINE.
HE IS TERRIFIC AT THAT.
IT'S WAY TIGHTER.
THE BEST CLIP YOU SHOWED WAS THE
BERNIE SANDERS CLIP SAYING THIS
IS TIGHTER THAN EVER BEFORE.
THE MOST UNUSUAL PRESIDENCY
EVER.
MOST PEOPLE PREDICT THAT THE
HOUSE AND SO FAR GOES TO THE
OTHER SIDE.
THE PRESIDENT IS DEMONSTRATING
HE CAN GET THE VOTER TURNOUT
EVEN IN A MID-TERM ELECTION.
I THINK IT WILL BE CLOSE.
YOU WON'T BE SURPRISED.
OUR FRIENDS WON'T BE SURPRISED.
RUSH LIMBAUGH WON'T BE SURPRISED
IF THE DEMOCRATS DON'T GET THE
BLUE WAVE.
>> Sean: I AM LESS WORRIED ABOUT
THE SENATE.
IF RICK SCOTT CAN WIN AS A
SENATE CANDIDATE IN FLORIDA AND
RON DESANTIS IS GOVERNOR AND
HEIDI HEITKAMP IS TOAST IN NORTH
CAROLINA.
THEN YOU HAVE JOHN TESTER IN THE
FIGHT OF HIS LIFE.
HE COULD LOSE IN MONTANA.
I HOPE THE PEOPLE IN INDIANA
REJECT THE LIBERTARIAN SO THEN
JOE IS TOAST.
IT'S THE HOUSE I AM WORRIED
ABOUT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH 15 DAYS.
THAT'S A LOT OF TIME ON THE
CLOCK TO GET HIS MESSAGE OUT.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO US DURING
THE CAMPAIGN.
EVERYBODY COUNTED US OUT AFTER
THE ACCESS HOLLYWOOD TAPE AND
WHAM HE IS THE 45th PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT WAS ONLY 30 DAYS.
15 DAYS, THAT'S A MOOCH AND A
HALF.
>> Sean: [LAUGHING].
I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU.
YOU CAPTURED SOMETHING IN YOUR
BOOK.
IT'S ON AMAZON.COM.
TRUMP THE BLUE COLLAR PRESIDENT.
THE PEOPLE HE IS HELPING ARE THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN.
THAT'S SCARAMUCCI AND "HANNITY."
ABSOLUTELY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO LOVE THE
GUY.
THEY ARE POSITIVE.
THE MEDIA CAN SAY WHATEVER THEY
WANT.
THE MORE MEDIA NONSENSE THROWN
AT THE PRESIDENT, THE MORE
PEOPLE ARE LIKE THE SCARAMUCCIs.
LIBERALS DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
MESSAGE.
THEY TALK OVER YOU.
THAT'S FINE.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS OF WRITING A
BOOK LIKE THIS, IF THE LIBERALS
READ IT THEY WILL SEE THE
PRESIDENT'S PLAYBOOK.
I AM A HUGE SUPPORTER.
I WANTED TO EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
WHY HE WON FROM MY VANTAGE
POINT.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO RUN.
CONGRATS.